Картопляне пюре з буряковим соком або рис із приправами.
На вибір - запечена риба чи  курячі нагетси.
А ще салати та домашній кетчуп.
Такий шкільний обід в білоцерківському ліцеї.
В місті цей заклад є взірцем реформи шкільного харчування.
А так їдять у шостій білоцерківській школі: картопля пюре та рибна котлета, і за бажанням помідор.
Тут впровадження нового шкільного меню лише починається.
Тож поки одні школи демонструють успіх - в інших реформа лише запускається. Чому так?
Давай, зайчик.
Котлета і рис.
В світлій відремонтованій їдальні білоцерківського ліцею діти шикуються в черги та один за одним самі обирають собі обід.
Меню формують за день до цього.
Нам дається вибір у Google-формах: суп чи борщ. І ми обираємо суп або борщ,  салат чи бурячок. І ми обираємо салат чи бурячок.
А раніше як було?
Раніше все було як завжди. Нам давали - ми собі їли. Я думаю, що зараз набагато краще.
З-поміж чотирнадцяти страв, які сьогодні в меню, десять - за рецептами шефкухаря Євгена Клопотенка.
До незвичних смакових поєднань кухаря тут звикли.
Адже за його рекомендаціями у школі готують вже більше року.
Раніше я взагалі не харчувалась, бо мама робила бутерброди, бо тут було трішки гірше.
А зараз - досить достойний вибір. У нас дабл меню, ми можемо обирати і у нас дуже смачно.
Тож реформоване меню тут давно, з першого вересня його лише розширили.
Появились і суп з рисом і томатом, борщ з чорносливом, картошка з буряком,
пюре, рис з орегано, салат з капусти і зеленим горошком,  кетчуп-соус по Клопотенку.
Річ в тому, що в 2020 році ліцей став одним з 10 навчальних закладів Київщини,
які отримали державну фінансову підтримку на впровадження реформи шкільного харчування.
За півтора мільйони гривень тут з нуля відремонтували харчоблок, приміщення їдальні, закупили всю необіхдну техніку та меблі.
Директор школи, він же депутат Білоцерківської міської ради, каже, що після впровадження нового меню
охочих обідати у школі стало в рази більше.
Нині це 800 учнів з понад тисячі, які навчаються в школі. Обід тут коштує 35 гривень.
Ми протягом 4 місяців працювали на старому обладнанні і дітям подобалось і відразу почався приріст учнів, які почали [ ред. харчуватись ].
Це певна ініціатива повинна йти з боку батьків, адміністрації,  старшокласників, - і тоді все вийде.
Та у більшості шкіл України перехід на нове меню лише починається.
І аби він пройшов спокійно, уряд встановив перехідний період до 1 січня 2022 року.
Тож за порушення нових норм харчування поки не штрафуватимуть.
Це пов'язано з тим, що чимало шкіл до кінця року мають тендери на закупівлю продуктів за своїм старим меню.
Крім того, для впровадження деяких позицій потрібна нова техніка.
Більшість українських шкіл, як, наприклад, шоста в Білій Церкві, не оновлювали харчболки з дня заснування. Цій кухні вже 40 років.
Плити міняти, жарочного шкаф міняти, протирочной машини немає.
Якщо крем-супи, то треба, щоб блендер був, у нас його немає.
Наприклад, навіть вінегрет кришити на 300 чоловік, це треба мати овочерізку для нарізки варених овочів.
Втім, вже зараз, запевняють кухарі, у всіх стравах зменшили кількість солі і  цукру.
Обмежили вживання хліба відповідно до нових норм.
Використовують менше жирів рослинного і тваринного походження, а отже, жодних сосисок чи ковбасних виробів не буде.
Діти зміни в харчуванні за перші кілька тижнів помітили.
А от про те, що меню має оновитись та стати різноманітним, аби був вибір страв, не чули.
Подобається все. І оладки! Ми їх чекаємо найчастіше!
Буде змінюватись меню в школі чули?
Ні, не чули.
Хочеться, щоб смачне щось давали, бо тут все як завжди.
Якщо буде більше овочів і менше цукру - це ж добре.
Я не хочу, щоб щось міняли мені і так меню нравиться.
Нормально. А особливо червоний борщ смачний. І запіканка теж дуже.
З понад тисячі учнів цієї школи в їдальню ходить лише триста учнів. Включно з пільговиками.
Керівництво школи сумнівається, що нове меню може збільшити кількість охочих перекусити. Нині обіди коштують 25 гривень.
Є певні побоювання з тим, як це все буде цей асортимент реалізовуватись.
По-друге, ми знаємо, що це меню до вподоби дітям, і вони практично 100% їдять.
Я не знаю, які будуть вподобання цих дітей до іншого меню. Можливо, треба буде ще звикати. Будемо бачити.
До хейту через нове меню, зокрема через відсутність сосиок, готовий і сам ініціатор реформи шкільного харчування.
Ми ж у дітей забрали єдине, що вони їли. Не єдине, але вони його обожнювали. І замість цього ми дамо їм гречку.
Ми нічого кращого їм не дали, в їхньому розумінні, ще гірше.
Тому ми отримаємо величезний хейт. Ми до нього готові.
Критика, що діти все одно не їдять, що Клопотенко… Ну, так.. Зараз півроку буде просто жесті.
Нове меню - це про користь для здоров'я і про збалансованість харчування.
Тож не варто орієнтуватись виключно на смакИ дітей, кажуть в Держпродспоживслужбі.
А те, що формування звички їсти корисне потребує часу та терпіння, помітили і у першій гімназії.
Салати та фрукти тут є щодня, однак далеко не всі діти їх беруть та гарно все доїдають.
Якби запровадили меню таке, як в Макдональдсі, то прийшло б і 100% дітей. Але це не здорове харчування.
Тож ми вдячні Клопотенку, який багато зробив для того, щоб харчування було здоровим і смачним.
Тим часом у Держпродспоживслужбі кажуть, що з майже тисячі вісімсот українських шкіл порушення на кухні є в понад тисячі.
Найпоширеніші проблеми – це недостатня кількість кухонного та столового посуду, холодильного і технологічного обладнання,
а також відсутність належних умов для миття рук у харчоблоках та обідніх залах.
Аби покращити стан шкільних їдалень, в Білій Церкві, наприклад, запровадили 5-річний план оновлення харчблоків у школах.
Те ж саме мають робити й інші громади, адже після реформи децентралізації саме вони відповідають за заклади освіти на своїй території.
Батькам же радять контролювати цей процес, як і реформу шкільного харчування. А в разі порушень звертатись в ДПСС.